okay thank you for this introduction yes
I will talk to you actually a little bit
about if you like personal history
because I kind of originated today or
was raised with formal language theory
so and this is kind of back to that a
little bit and well maybe many of you
might think just from their education
bachelor course or whatever that finite
automata are really the easy things and
nothing really interesting about that
but as most of you think on graph
problems I mean of course automaton in a
sense nothing else then
especially colored directed graphs so
you can easily think of them in terms of
harder problems and the three classical
problems I will mostly focus on humor
talk I am falling ones so non
universality means you're given an
automaton and with some input alphabet
Sigma and you are asked whether the
language accepted by the automaton is
just Sigma star so every word over this
language or in equivalence given to
automata a-1 a-2
we are asked whether or not the two
languages accepted by diesel ultimately
are the same or I know what's the same
and intersection non emptiness
well you're given a bunch of automata
and you ask if there is any word
accepted by everybody yeah so these are
the three main problems I will focus on
why well if you think about it for for a
sec you will notice immediately from
what you've probably learned in in
bachelor times that for DFAS at least
Nanyan will empty and equivalence are P
time so quite easy however if I turn my
attention to anaphase all three problems
sort of suddenly become pspace-complete
and
this is also true if I consider this
intersection on emptiness for DFAS
so this is just the kind of classical
status and maybe even more interesting
to those interested in graphs is that if
I go sort of towards anaphase now for a
sec do to be some hardness and softness
results are just presented then a case
is the fact that all these problems are
still hard name in this case np-complete
on unary input alphabets
okay if you have you know input
alphabets but doesn't mean basically you
can simply forget about this structure
as being an automaton it's just a
directed graph nothing else and so you
can also kind of think of like non
you've a universality or university in
terms of graphs if you like to have it
like that so maybe you are living here
in this blue house and you want to visit
somebody in the red house and in between
there's some directed graph which kind
of describes the possibilities how to
walk from the blue house to the red
house and somehow and say your doctor
advised you to walk as long as possible
but so you want to stay into your
schedule so maybe you know each working
each of these arcs takes one minute and
you have 35 minutes left and you want to
know whether now you can use up all the
time to work from here to here for
instance so this is kind of the
universal hilarity problem in these guys
on diary graphs here so I must underline
it's important we direct it here for
undirected graphs this house problem
becomes easy anyways and as I mentioned
these and problems are hard for you know
alphabets or in
Luxio theoretic terms for tele anaphase
and this hardness was already shown by
stockmeyer Mar long ago why I'm
mentioning this year and I'm also
putting up this nasty slide a pretty
technical slide because and we are what
I want to go to in the following is
trying to get some lower bound results
and so Ana eth and therefore it's for
instant interesting that stuff my
admirers prove actually reduced from
three set and so in order to understand
what kind of lower bounds we can
immediately wrap from there reduction
and how what are the weaknesses where do
we have to improve on that to get better
relevance we have to understand what's
going on here so basically how can we
actually codify anything within you know
real languages so the basic trick is to
use chinese reminder theorem and so you
similar actually last talk there was
something like that at least in passing
so for instance you just if you take the
first and primes if you have an free set
instance on three variables and m
crosses like an in this example P 1 2 P
2 3 P 3 5 and now such unary word like a
to the Z they encode an assignment alpha
well if and only if the set is the same
as the assignment to X I model u P i
okay for instance and if you're assigned
L 4 says well x1 is 0 so false x2 is
true x3 is true then the number is
something like 16 at least if these are
all the variables that appear otherwise
you have to basically do more of that
so have you have a larger number say so
given that what do you have to express
in order to encode satisfiability well
first of all I try to write down what it
means to be some word which is not
including any assignment okay that means
that basically we falsify this condition
yeah so we have for instance that J
equals to less than P indicate prime
such that this to the word of this form
and so this is one thing we have to
check so that all the assignments which
kind of survive I'm sorry all the words
that kind of survive actually codifying
assignments and then second thing is
that I want to express that an
assignment falsifies clause
so LJ is kind of given need some somehow
this statement that a certain assignment
in this case this Z sub set KJ is
actually falsified so me which means
that okay what does it mean if I want to
falsify Clause there's exactly one way
to do this and this assignment it's
actually codified in this kind of thing
so the next thing you have to see that
the automaton that kind of can be used
to express these languages are very
simple so they're basically cycles of a
certain length somehow this multiple of
the speak case and taking all this
together it's not so hard to see that
well you gather prove or if you take any
number and in number so either it does
not call the finest
or it does and if it does then well if
it's really in the language then it
falsifies some clause so therefore we
have this kind of reduction and how many
how many states does an NFA have that
basically takes all these together so
you might recall that Union is an easy
operation on any face so basically we
have to look at the question how many
states do automata need to process this
and this and just because we have 3sat
instances we know that this is basically
well something like P n cube states at
most and now again something similar to
the previous talks well this is somehow
like n log n in in brackets square cubed
and and how many of these languages do
we have M so we have something like this
so all in all we would get immediately
from this old reduction son such a lower
bound so how can we improve to this or
is it possible that also improve on this
somehow so so how can we actually show
this what are the algorithms available
to show your ability and so the textbook
algorithm we all know would basically
convert this NFA could be give to DFA
and you would have something like this
complexity as for your algorithm in the
worst case but there is some improvement
and namely this special case of you
neural input alphabets
there are some some well ifs know that
the worst case size of give face is
slightly less than this namely this it's
a kind of funny formula so we are
getting now into this structural
complexity issues of foreign languages
but anyway so this is what you can get
so that there are still some difference
as you can see and so next I want to
is a bit how to improve on these lower
bounds so one thing you might have seen
with this an idea to express that a
certain clause is falsified well we need
these three primes to be multiplied
well maybe you can do better if you
don't go for clauses but instead say for
edges of graph so what does it mean not
to satisfy net maybe you more let's get
to the idea of coloring it's not that
far away and so also this morning we
have seen that we have also this L star
2 to the little o of mm and number of
edges lower bound for 3 colorability so
therefore we can basically mimic the
algerie duction of stockmeyer and mire
and adapted to to this situation model
details say and what we get is then
instead of this 1 over 4 or 1 more free
but there still goes Absalon hanging
around why does it come from it comes
from this poly logarithmic terms which
are kind of inherited by this encoding
with the first n prime numbers but we
had some little waste the waste was to
throw away many of the possible encoding
numbers due to the restriction that we
own interests in those which are 0 1
modulo something so we have some space
left we can actually use this by a more
clever encoding and well with some
tricks as I mentioned you get a you get
away losing these minus Epsilon thingy
so this is what we finally get at the
moment but of course there's still a gap
so I don't know how to fill it but
anyways
this is how it is at the moment for the
inequivalent problem for nFA's we
basically get the same kind of result at
the moment at least so still this so
this kind of lower bound and this kind
of upper bound so you might think that
this is a bit of a harder problem and it
might be actually that it's easier to
improve here on some kind of bounce but
I don't know so at the moment the
business open have even worse if we look
at this intersection problem then so we
are given a bunch of interface and I try
to see whether or not the intersection
of all these languages is empty around
empty then we can get some really weird
function here as a lower bound where
this little K is the number of of
automata we are dealing with well it is
basically looking at the previous
constructions and as I try to indicate
already if you look back at the
interface or also dear face that
accepting this type of languages or also
these type of languages they are very
special and easy structure so therefore
it's not hard to see that they can be
used as cornerstones to look into the
compliment in complementation at least
for nFA's and DFAS are complementation
for these languages yeah and then you
look for the non emptiness instead of
the universality or or non universality
on the other hand so this is basically
the gist of this country of construction
and looking back also then figures so no
for the colouring stuff we get this kind
of scenery and that basically gives
these kind of funny figures up there but
unfortunately really unfortunately up to
now the only thing I know
to really solve this algorithm Utley is
doing some kind of product automaton
construction and this gives me an
automaton which has this many states
basically and so this is at least my
current bound and well I must admit
these are pretty far off this situation
can be a little bit improved if I now
abandon this very specific unary
alphabet thingy so if I now go into the
case of bounded alphabets first of all
say binary alphabet then I can also show
that doing some different but still
related reduction from 3-coloring we can
rule out algorithms with a running turn
of ode to the to the little of Q queuing
in them of state of the automaton for
the non universality problem and which
is actually now matching this DFA
construction I mentioned before so in
that case we are fine and well basically
the same we get also if we get so this
was for excuse me for in equivalence
same kind of our construction same idea
so that is fine so for that case we max
lower and upper bound and also even with
the kind of trivial algorithm like the
subset contrast engineer so it's not
nothing
nothing cute in the sense that nothing
very weird but still it works if we look
at intersection non emptiness for da
face so then we again get some things
which are just derived from the previous
constructions which are not really tied
so to speak for the case of unbounded
alphabets okay now we are moving further
on so now the alphabet is actually a
part of alphabets eyes and part of the
input then again we get
some kind of matching bounce and
basically so ruling out given the
intersection problem for DFAS okay dia
face each with at most three states
which is not too much so we get this
kind of lower bound and so of course the
product which I'm Burton construction
gives you this kind of other bounce so
and this is times pretty tight in at
least I know eighty eight so maybe to
give you an idea how this construction
works because it's pretty simple so for
the vertices and for the extras we have
some kind of automata so and what do
they do well this automaton basically
tells you that okay and what sorry
what's the alphabet that's crucial here
what's the alphabet the alphabet is this
kind of product thingy so which means I
can have pairs of vertices and colors
which is quite a lot of information in
the alphabet and so this AV automata are
very basically ensure so here we start
here we end that there is exactly one
color associated to each vertex that's a
spelled out there and then this kind of
automata tell you that there is some a
at least because we intersect all these
there is some color a such that both
ends of this edge are colored with the
same color this basically telling you
this and therefore well intersecting all
this gives you their reduction basically
yeah okay so just to sum up this part
and I would be quick with the other one
so we have well basically one line with
unbound alphabets where we're kind of
happy
especially if you fix cue somehow then
this is really all tied mmm fine for the
other cases we have some sometimes
really strange situations I saw I'm just
talking about this function in the
exponent which looks a bit weird but
otherwise it would be too small so so we
have always these kind of things for
instance which are kind of weird and
this is even worse in a sense if you
look for lower and upper bounds but this
is how it is at the moment for us maybe
you have ideas how to improve these
things so please tell me
I wanted to sketch at least they were
following a couple of minutes some more
problems so you see we are just up here
so but I will be speeding up now so
there are a really couple of more
problems on fire automata which are hard
for instance a periodicity well you I
will be short with this slide but this
is one of the most interesting sub
regular language classes they can be
described for instance by in many ways
so many characterizations one of them is
to say well we try to build up regular
expressions but not with cleany star but
so starting from final steps booting
operations and concatenation nothing
else
so booing its operations include
complementation so therefore you can get
infinite sets but it's still you don't
have spinny star and these are they have
many many ways to see this for instance
algebraically with so bubbles groups of
the syntactic moderate stuffy I won't go
into these details but just to mention
we can basically mimic an ultra duck
use an old reduction of tracks down
that is kind of not so interesting
anymore for the classical world because
Jack stone only showed that trying to
see whether a given finite automaton
accepts a an apparatchik language is Cal
and P hard so when it is known to be a
pspace-complete this problem
so the in a sense this reduction is not
no more interesting but it's interesting
for us because it gives you this lower
bound if you analyze it reanalyze under
eth conditions while currently this is
what we know for really showing or
testing a theory that you see for a
given a DFA who said T of DV so there is
still some gap but andreas at least is
hoping that he can improve from that
green stuff e a bit given side using
some odd break tools basically another
thing you might have heard of
synchronizing words that is related to
one of the most famous open on
comunitario conjectures in in formal
language theory the [ __ ] conjecture
and I won't go into details here again
but just mention one more kind of add on
to what we've done before namely if we
look at the problem to synchronize a
given set of states in the sense that we
want to require that there is a word W
that if I start my automaton in Q or in
Q prime it doesn't matter for any Q P
Prime in my Q think set it will give me
the lead-in to the same state it's funny
right up for that so this can be solved
in our star 2 of 2 to the Q basic goes
by a subset construction while you can
throw a matching lower bound for that or
we control yes and so at least four so
for bounded
binary alphabets for instant as well
okay let me jump to five minutes yes
jumping fire automata are a concept
which it's kind of uses finer terms in
different way namely it allows to read
portions of the input here and there say
for instance if I have this file
otamatone and I try to start it now it
can read this it can jump here in the
input or here doesn't matter I read this
part and then I read some other parts of
these are just two ways to read the same
input word and I go around go around go
around well until I'm finished of course
so what I get is in this case all words
that have the same numbers of A's B's
and C's which is a non regular language
and non context-free language as you all
know so for this jaya phase there's even
hearted for instance for uniform
membership so there are actually
different proofs he aspired by the same
stuff now but but a different Maya and
so they had a proof for that in some
other models but which are equivalent
and we have another one in Wojcik moral
does another one effect actually this is
one which we use for the ETH thingy to
basically have again some well lower
bound like this for the universe
membership while the upper bound we
currently know is this one so it's not
exactly matching but still some work to
do this post refer on fire automata is
another way of using fire automata for
reading pictures pictures
two-dimensional object so basically this
little guy here what does it do it will
read through the picture like well a cow
plus so this is this kind of
boustrophedon thingy so going all the
way around and it will
detective is born us and for these kind
of way of working on this
two-dimensional arrays or pictures we
can show that for instance non emptiness
is np-complete and some other stuff II
and if I look at this from Vth
perspective I can see that for instance
I get something like 2 to the little o
of square root of Q lower bound while
for the emptiness problem while I have
the Q 2 Q algorithm I don't know better
at the moment for testing emptiness non
emptiness for these tai deferred
automaton ok let me conclude although
you might think that ultimate if I don't
omit are not that interesting anymore
there are still some quite interesting
hard problems for these and I think
apart from our paper on synchronizing
words frankly speaking I don't think
there's anything we have ever done on
this before so there are still many
concrete questions to match these lower
and upper bounds currently at least for
instance these funny I mean I don't know
how to get anything like that in the
reaction no idea - practice say so and
things like that maybe there are other
ways to do with this apart from DFA
construction and just one last thought
on this and currently as tradition goes
with Fyodor potometer theory as well we
are measuring complexity always in the
number of states well number of nodes of
a graph if you wanted but of course you
can look at it from the position of the
number of transitions haven't done this
so far but maybe this gives you new
ideas at least to match lower and upper
bounds ok thank you for attention and
thanks for people who helped me come
here
so the reason that the strong ETH
doesn't appear is just that you have
another entred does it that was a
complete bound like the three to the
cave okay sorry I did I didn't look at
it did for that case but actually they
are us okay I just packed it in so sorry
and there are just a second for instance
for this problem you can also ask or for
this type of problems and or have
additional parameter like the number of
the length of the the word you want to
have as a testimony for this or this
property for on this w and if you
parameterize by that then you get some
lower bounds on SE th and I think
similar construction also work for other
problems so if you I mean you always
have this idea of having a testimony you
need you need some witness to show you
okay you have not your non-universal
stuff like FL and if you bound that so
that's also known as the K bound or il
bounded problem in literature then you I
think that would lead to some sath page
based results but I didn't check that
for the other cases it's just my gut
feeling